einen tag lang das günstigste auf der
karte bestellen vor ein zwei wochen habe
ich das ganze mal mit den teuersten
gerichten gemacht heute die unliebsame
variante das günstigste und ich bin
wirklich gespannt was mich erwarten
würde ich meinen haben ein frühstück
mittag und abendessen und jeweils die
günstigste option wird auf jeden fall
interessant ich glaube ich werde sehr
viel salat essen heute ich glaube ich
werde sehr viel lust auf andere sachen
von der karte haben aber wir bringen es
hinter uns und gehen zunächst einmal
frühstück sie sind leicht bei kaffee
saures denn natürlich müssen wir auch
heute wo wir das billigste bestellen
eine kleinigkeit finden wir frühstücken
könnt wichtig immer nur volle mahlzeiten
keine vorspeisen keine beilagen deshalb
hoffe ich dass was gibt's bekommen
[Musik]
erste seite der karte - aus gebratenen
champignons granatapfel wo aussieht auch
klingt richtig gut ein geiles humus brot
drei pancakes mit butter und ahornsirup
ohne tore
ich liebe blieb es nicht aber hey guck
mal ist helfen wir sind jetzt auch nicht
auf den tipp das ist eigentlich sehr gut
lange habe ich auf jeden fall power für
den tag der kurzer prozess würde ich
sagt er auf 50 ist das günstigste 650
das günstig sind ja ich hätte so ein
spiegelei mit brot erwartet dachte humus
ist seit der so die untergrenze aber
anscheinend was kostet denn bedingt
guckst du doch mal fünf euro 50 und dani
exchange teil zweier auch brot 500 habe
ich doch gesagt hast du sie
ex-coach
getränke sind ausgenommen aber auch
gerade da ist ja auch dann mal wichtig
zu sehen so können sie tanzen reiten ist
einmal das günstigste der karte die hexe
okay dann mit pochierten ei
duncan dayton wäre wohl schön gewesen
sei es eine ruhige allen anträgen
gestellt das muss nicht aber wer schon
gewesen ich glaube der futterneid
ungleich erst die bilder haben
ziemlich
bitten dankeschön eines jahr normal aber
ich habe den tollsten also ich sage
nicht dass es nicht mit beiden von euch
sofort tauschen würde aber es sieht auch
ja farben nicht geht da auch mehr sagen
ich mache aber ich bin also ich bin
glücklich für 550 fans cafés papa das
ist uns auch wichtig
das ist nicht erwartet und gesund ist
das allemal
ich sehe direkt müssen das erst mal mit
pfeffer salz hätten weil da ist noch
nichts wenn man auf scoach ist kann man
selbst noch ein bisschen optimieren
66 euro wert probiert als erstes
natürlich passiert das auch unter
inkontinenz werden kann die große schwer
zwischen 1 aber jetzt
sagte ehrlich gehabt jahrhundert und
beantwortet aber das eigelb allein so
cremig brauchst eine mutter aus gespielt
und dort gar nicht sie herkommen das
ding ist das ist so eins um instagram
zuhause schillernde schüssel vor wenn du
niemanden beeindrucken muss zuerst gegen
ist überall dran man sieht das
geschmacklich und vergleichen ist eine
leichte süße
ich sagte ehrlich fünf produkte ist der
hammer die für dieses frühstück
übertrieben und sagt ehrlich manchmal so
einfach ich glaube ganz echt und kannst
sagen du bist gesünder unterwegs gibt es
günstiger unser jürgens plus genauso gut
gesättigt also wo ist der nachteil
was soll ich sagen ich fühle mich frisch
im sattel ist ja weniger zeit sofern es
weiter gehen also ein auto wird ich habe
so günstig kommen wir vielleicht noch
mal weg war schon echt günstig für essen
gehen aber ich bin gespannt auf
mittagessen und ich würde sagen wir sind
dort soll jetzt wird's unangenehme gehe
nämlich jetzt in sapporo das sind was
die luft shopping ecke in köln
dementsprechend auch dass oskar ist das
restaurant sehr gehoben und daran jetzt
das billig herzustellende stehen wir
dann bestimmt gericht als
geringverdiener betrachtet aber finden
sich dass wir trotzdem lecker ich würde
sagen system gedribbelt internet zu
bestellen ein sehr großes revier
über die regel keine beilagen keine
vorspeisen sondern wirklich nur
hauptgericht und erst jetzt richtig gut
gehen meldungen der stadt haren
riesengarnelen
nicht
erst
mit mit halber schlag sichergestellt
jetzt geht's los jetzt wird gesägt
inside out zu tirol zählt das zählt das
als eine mahlzeit weiter so holle wenn
man ist ja eigentlich nicht einen
überlegenen schon mittags partner zählt
sowieso nicht werden
salate wer jetzt ein bisschen schade ich
hatte ja schon ein
salatteller bisher günstigste käse salat
58 wird's wieder in seiner art für mich
sieht danach aus dass sie wirkt
schneller aus die günstigste so viel
holz 1950 kann man weiß leute ist heute
ein besonderer tag
wenn wir schon heute einmal das
billigste immer bestehen müssen können
wir jetzt dass das teure wassertrinken
dem buch von sat 1 sieht auch sehr gut
das ist aber leider ein euro zu teuer
ich glaube der ziegenkäse wird vom
einschalten ich glaube auch das
stimmrecht ich darf ich das letzte stück
weiter darf
[Musik]
ziegenkäse super super gut ich mag auch
das blaubeeren und cashewkerne drin sind
sagt das haben wir so ein bisschen das
anders sie ja was anderes war vor selbst
gestellt also er ist auf jeden fall noch
mal eine ecke besser ist sich seiner
passion bahn also wirklich
supergut super frisch und sagte ehrlich
eine ist dass du data corp
[Musik]
der ist süß und herzhaft frischer salat
hudson an den schaltungen haben jetzt
außen rum noch honig sind die wände
großen prüfen das ist ja von super sagt
werden wir ihnen jetzt noch mal 190 man
nur drei mal wieder verziehen wird
hoffentlich richten aber wir werden
sehen was mir schmeckt die frage der
fragen war es jetzt ein apple teilt
vollwertige mahlzeit das ding jetzt ich
habe da brauche ich den größten romane
ja jetzt
deshalb stand jetzt fühle ich mich
eigentlich einfach nur so frischen
weitem nicht so erschlagen aber ich bin
auch nicht umbringen ich könnte jetzt
weiter es muss nicht also im prinzip für
den moment jetzt alles kleines genau
richtigen aber ich habe so die sorge
dafür dass tipp den nachtstunden aber
wie gesagt wenn er in abend essen und es
tut mir das haus wo ich keinen sache
bekommen ich freue mich stressen haben
aber ich will nicht wissen was für das
teuerste zur letzter stopp ihr seht es
ist sehr grau dort wo wir hier unterwegs
sind wir sind mitten in der innenstadt
gehen zu weit gespannt was das billigste
biker ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt gar
nicht glaube ich habe immer alles hier
bestellt entweder du plessis oder
sandwich
sie ist eigentlich keine große
überraschung was ist erwartet örtlich
überlegt gleich hätte holen können aber
es irgendwie deren beilage sein dass uns
jetzt auch befristet eine große portion
oder sagt aber ich muss sagen bisher hat
die sättigung vom mittagessen wirklich
gut an gehalt und jetzt auch nicht vor
da hab ich mehr wie alle top speed auf
mark webber fest die ganzen addons
begriff schaffen wir auch unsere top
platz einfach so gerne puristisch und
schöne so sehen geschmolzen naja sie mal
auseinander
leider sehen
dazu mario ich spüre dass ich alles
zunichte was mir mein körper heute gut
bessere ernährung als sonst aber schön
in die major eintippen das geht es um
vier wissen wegen die euro 75 wir sagen
sie so dass es künftig aber wenn man
darüber nachdenkt die sagen nicht dass
preis aber ist das günstig verkaufen das
ist durch so ein wichtiges selbst der
stürmer hessen was aber auch guttun kann
sagen ich versuche es ist auf jeden fall
der konkurrenz weg vom geschmack was
soll ich sagen das ist butter brot käse
und
das ist ja alles was den anbieter
mehr davon auf ein junge deshalb werde
ich wahrscheinlich noch nicht gesättigt
seien davon auch weil er keine substanz
dabei ist aber deutlich wir so viel
essen oder ein video sich dort sind ein
paar tagen bisschen weniger als letzte
mahlzeit zwar lecker muss früh zu sagen
also man kann nichts dazu danken das ist
das fazit von heute wir sehen schon
gerufen achter seid ihr wieder leute ich
bin jetzt an gestalten weil das
kreativteam ich so fertig gemacht hat
ich schwöre ich will einfach mich nicht
mehr bewegen wissen heute hat alles
zunichte gemacht was ich einen gesunden
sachen davor gegessen habt aber es war
okay also insgesamt fast zwar wieder ein
erfolg muss ich wirklich sagen also ich
hab ja nur bei guten spots gegessen
dementsprechend waren auch die günstigen
option wirklich sehr sehr lecker und was
soll ich sagen ich habe wieder wie das
wird uns heute noch mal eine weitere
perspektive gegeben das teuerste ist
nicht mal das beste das günstigste ist
nicht immer das schlechteste entwickelt
einfachen geschmack und ist das worauf
er bock habt leute danke dass ihr dieses
video gesehen habe abonniert diesen
kanal und ich gehe wieder schaffen